i like chop lover that's a good one have
you ever had it it's still out there
no but i just picture it it sounds gross
people i guess hate it because
everybody's like it's always like the
last thing it gets a bad rap yeah
you know what else gets a bad rap um
fish
when people go this smells fishy because
i feel like bad for the fish because he
goes
yeah i'm a fish and they're like oh
fishy's by the way the grossest thing
you could smell and they're like
i am a fish uh why is that gross i'm
just smelling like yeah i'm on [ __ ]
they don't give us menus to other fishes
they
it's cool but the other two humans they
hate it sometimes i wonder if fish are
male or female here on my plate
you know and sometimes crossed my mind
but oh you asked who the [ __ ]
i'll ask the waiter oh and they'll be
like let me check
and they never come back someone quit
working there sometimes at that point
that's funny they should leave the
building because
they don't get that a lot i'm sure
they're like [ __ ] me are you eating
fish dick how do you figure this out
yeah maybe i was eating fish sticks
instead of fish sticks
yeah i just want to know i just want to
make sure i'm not fish
dicks man fish sticks were good remember
them oh
i mean in the lazy mom [ __ ]
dictionary it's so perfect
or the kids you would have to make them
yourself did you ever have to make your
own your mom made them the greatest
thing is
you could be a lazy mom and what you're
doing is giving your kids a dream
like if she goes all right fish sticks
and i'm like she did it
it's my birthday yeah meanwhile she's
like [ __ ] throw that goddamn cookie
sheet
put eight of those [ __ ] on there i do
pizza rolls we had
fish sticks the easiest [ __ ] and i loved
it so much well pizza rolls isn't really
a dinner i think fish sticks at least
you have that element of you know you
got a protein
one of your meals there's definitely
fish in there one of the food groups
yeah
[ __ ] 90 breading yeah i like the fish
i go to mcdonald's and i go to the
drive-through and i go
what's the fillet fish of the day and
they go excuse me and i go is it
branzino
is it it's not swordfish again and they
go they just pause and i go
quarter pounder with cheese like okay
quarter pound of cheese they don't know
what to say
dude one thing about fish though is some
of them have those little bones in it
and they never
they never act like they do you know
what i'm talking about like
sometimes you'll get a part of the fish
you're like oh there's eight little
bones grotesque yeah the hard part about
fish is
i see them first of all when they ring
the fish with the head to the table i'm
[ __ ] out
yeah i don't want to see him going why
me yeah jamaicans
it's very jamaican i don't like that
it's sickening i don't like eating the
eyeball which
please call it a delicacy i mean i like
when they label it adele because
you're not tricking me well dude even
when they give you the head you don't
eat the eyeball
you just leave it in there i don't know
some people like other countries they
think
different parts are great yeah i mean
i'm sure [ __ ] we eat is gross
but i'm used to it now i don't think i
can start
with some of the stuff they eat yeah
it's too late in the game
like i ate liverwurst as a kid and i
liked it somehow my mom snuck that
in there and then i like it with mustard
on toast but
today i wouldn't start with liverworts
hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one